[Musique]
alors effectivement dans la question de
la transmission
on transmet ce que l'on sait mais le
mettre en perspective avec ce que l'on
ne sait pas est aussi très utile
chaque jour des dizaines voire des
centaines de personnes consacrent leur
vie leur passion à transmettre au grand
public
ce que l'on sait de la préhistoire et
notamment des mégalithes les mégalithes
ne sont que vous voyez derrière moi ce
sont ces architectures de grosses
pierres comme leurs noms l'indiquent et
qui date de l'époque du néolithique le
néolithique c'est la dernière période de
la préhistoire
la plus récente si vous voulez ce sont
les alignements de carnac stonehenge en
angleterre ni au grunge en irlande
décide que vous connaissez et bien à la
fin de chaque visite guidée à la fin de
chaque conférence ou même de discussions
informelles
il se retrouvera toujours quelqu'un pour
vous dire avec un petit regard malicieux
mais en fait vous savez toujours pas
pourquoi est ce qu'on a construit les
menhirs et le pire c'est que c'est vrai
mais c'est ce qui donne tout le sel à la
connaissance de ses monuments de
préhistoire près histoire tout est dit
il s'agit de monuments construits avant
l'histoire avant l'invention de
l'écriture avant que ces hommes et ces
femmes est le moyen technique de nous
transmettre
l'exact dessins de leurs oeuvres il ya
un paradoxe la recherche a sans cesse
progresser sur ce sujet des chercheurs
et parfois le travail de toute une vie
on fouille et documenté produit de la
connaissance
donc on peut contempler ces monuments
mais on peut aussi se demander le
rapport entre ce que l'on sait et ce que
l'on ne sait pas et il quelque chose qui
nous enseigne alors on va juste réciter
un petit peu les choses
j'ai un métier formidable je dirige
l'association qui s'occupe de préparer
la candidature au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco des mégalithes de carnac du
golfe du morbihan et de la baie de
quiberon
c'est une éponge une petite équipe
composée de spécialistes dans des
domaines variés et qui mettent toute
leur passion à ce projet je ne suis pas
archéologues je n'ai aucune compétence
sur la matière et je l'assumé
parfaitement mon métier c'est la gestion
et la communication publique c'est à
dire de rendre intelligible au plus
grand nombre des sujets parfois ardu
parfois complexe parfois techniques mais
qui ont un intérêt collectif
j'enseigne également dans plusieurs
universités depuis près d'une dizaine
d'années et la transmission du savoir
pour moi c'est une passion troisième
élément je suis breton alors non pas que
breton me donne une compétence
particulière mais c'est juste pour vous
dire que les mégalithes ils sont en moi
cette manière ils sont mois on nous
identifient aux menhirs et nous nous
identifions à cet objet et quand on aime
profondément quelque chose et j'aime
profondément la bretagne on veut
partager sa flamme
le rapport que je fais avec l'amour il
n'est pas par hasard
ce n'est pas parce que l'on ne sait pas
pourquoi est ce que l'on aime quelqu'un
que l'on est moins amoureux séparés avec
les mégalithes
c'est pas parce qu'on ne sait pas tout
que l'on ne sait rien pour fixer un peu
les choses dans le temps
je vais appeler à la rescousse le plus
fantastique avocat que tous les
monuments de patrimoine aurait pu et
peuvent rêver obélix obélix et ces
géniaux inventeurs uderzo et goscinny
ont été les promoteurs les plus
extraordinaires des menhirs on les
connaît partout dans le monde je donne
un exemple le créateur japonais du jeu
vidéo les pokémon quand il crée son jeu
vidéo dans une france un peu imaginaire
il représente la tour eiffel le château
de versailles et les alignements de
carnac
il fait pas de les représenter il vient
avec toute son équipe se documenter sur
un monument qui l'a fait rêver depuis
des années et bien obélix on peut que le
remercier mais il a fait aussi une
terrible gaffe il a rajeuni
catastrophiquement ce patrimoine obélix
et qui obélix et un gaulois un gaulois
contemporain jules césar le pôle jules
césar d'ailleurs eh bien ça veut dire
c'est un homme qui a vécu il y a deux
mille ans or les mégalithes leur
construction ont commencé il ya plus de
sept mille ans rendez vous compte de
l'erreur on n'est pas dans l'épaisseur
du trait pour schématiser obélix est
deux fois plus proche de nous qu'ils ne
l'étaient des hommes du néolithique
alors imaginez le travail avant même
d'expliquer aux gens que le fait de ne
pas tout savoir est intéressant sur ses
monuments il faut leur désapprendre ce
qu'il pense déjà
et donc il faut vraiment être admiratifs
pour le travail que font tous les guides
du patrimoine qui passent leur temps à
senoble cette noble tâche
alors après tout ça il ya ce que l'on
sait et ce que l'on sait provoque un
sentiment de vertige
pour illustrer tout ça on va aller à
locmariaquer locmariaquer ce une
presqu'île dans golfe du morbihan une
magnifique commune et sur le site des
mégalithes site des mégalithes et gérer
aujourd'hui par le centre des monuments
nationaux
on va aller voir le grand menhir brisé
ce grand menhir brisé quand il était
debout
il mesurait plus de 20 mètres de haut et
pesait 300 tonnes d'imaginer que des
hommes du néolithique des milliers
d'années avant l'invention des métaux
avec les techniques de l'époque ont pu
tailler une stèle de 20 mètres de long
qui pèse 300 tonnes est tout bonnement
impensable crée un sentiment de vertige
mais le savoir progresse et des analyses
récentes sur la nature du granit de
cette pierre nous ont appris quelque
chose que cette pierre ne vient pas de
locmariaquer mais de la presqu'île de
rhuys à plus de dix kilomètres de là que
ces hommes et ces femmes peut-être en
brie ici avec les moyens de l'époque des
milliers d'années avant l'invention de
la roue
bien avant la domestication des chevaux
à transporter sur plus de 10 km une
pierre de 300 tonnes qui pesait 20
mètres est tout bonnement impensable et
le vertige a grandi et on n'en est pas
au bout de nos surprises
ce camp les spécialistes et les
scientifiques qui s'occupe de la
formation du golfe du morbihan nous dise
une chose
cette pierre à ces déplacés sur plus de
10 km mais qu'en plus elle a traversé de
très larges étendues d'eau et qu'elle a
donc certainement flotter là le vertige
est terrible allez demander aujourd'hui
un architecte naval
de faire flotter une pierre de 300
tonnes avec les moyens de l'époque et
vous dira qu'il peut pas le faire et là
je vous parle d'un monument sur un site
on en a 500 des sites autour du golfe du
morbihan des sites néolithiques on peut
l'illustrer par deux choses avec les les
haches polies que vous avez trouvé au
musée de préhistoire de carnac ou au
musée d'archéologie de vannes
c'est magnifique h dans une pierre qui
s'appelle la jadéite proche du proche du
jade et on trouve en bretagne on les a
trouvés il ya très longtemps les
archéologues centre où il ya très
longtemps sur ces sites et on pensait
qu'elle était extraction relativement
locales et bien les analyses récentes
montrent qu'une partie d'entre elles
viennent d'espagne ou des alpes
italiennes et là encore des milliers
d'années avant l'art où on allait
chercher à des milliers de kilomètres
c'est pierre c'était pas un pays
différent pour eux c'était certainement
un monde différent
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout ça on
peut contempler ce vertige
si on veut on peut aussi en tirer des
interprétations et il y en a toujours eu
de plus ou moins sérieuses d'ailleurs
mis en a toujours eu c'est pas mon
propos aujourd'hui on peut aujourd'hui
c'est ce que ça va nous apprendre par
exemple sur la responsabilité que l'on a
vis-à-vis de ce patrimoine
les menhirs surtout nous en bretagne ils
peuvent parfois nous déranger ils
empêchent de construire une route nous
empêche de construire une piscine dans
le fond d'un jardin mais détruire un
menhir s'est coupé un lien avec notre
passé et c'est peut-être s'empêcher de
trouver les choses dans l'avenir avec
des moyens techniques que l'on n'a pas
encore aujourd'hui autre sujet sur ce
que le ça nous apprend de notre rapport
avec autrui quand on le connaît mal les
hommes du néolithique il se sont pas des
cris on sait pas à quoi ils ressemblent
ils n'ont pas dit comment est ce qu'on
lit mais j'imagine des hommes
préhistoriques barbu hirsute habillé en
peau de bête ou pensé qu' on est capable
quand on est capable de tailler une
pierre de plus de 20 mètres de long 2
300 tonnes et l'a dépassée sur 10 km on
n'est pas capable ce coût d'un pantalon
ou de se raser la barbe voire même de se
parfumer que 16 ça nous apprend que
mettre en perspective nos connaissances
et ce que l'on ne sait pas aussi peut
nous apprendre à nous dire on voit
peut-être mal
autrui alors ces questions là elle nous
amène plein de choses mais quels sont
leur importance et leur importance elle
est fantastique elle est gigantesque et
aujourd'hui plus que jamais quand les
terroristes les obscurantistes partout
dans le monde commence toujours par
détruire notre patrimoine le plus ancien
c'est ça qui va détruire ces d'autres
liens avec notre passé et surtout un
lien avec des objets de recherche d
objet de questionnement et le
questionnement amène quoi le
questionnement amène la tolérance le
questionnement appel amène une meilleure
intelligence d'autrui de nos ancêtres
comme de nos contemporains
alors ces monuments considère
aujourd'hui qui sont sacrés c'est ce qui
rend peut-être le plus difficile à
comprendre mais c'est ce qui aussi nous
fait nous fait quelque chose à nous
certaine manière ces hommes du
néolithique on connaît pas le nom leur
dieu on connaît pas le détail de leur
foi on connaît pas leur univers mental
mais on sait qu'ils en avaient pourquoi
on voit ses monuments ses monuments on
les admire on a un peu d'empathie avec
eux et les hommes du néolithique
ils sont comme nous ils sont nous ils
ont notre taille le cerveau est
exactement le même
il s'était il ya 7000 ans et bien
pourtant ne connais pas tous deux et on
peut rentrer en communion avec ce qu'ils
ont produit et ce qu'ils nous ont
laissés voilà le rapport entre ce que
l'on sait ce que l'on ne sait pas notre
connaissance du patrimoine
et bien en fait ça peut être un
fantastique antidote contre tous les a
priori ça peut être un outil pour
produire de la tolérance et vous
m'accorderez quand même qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose d'un peu rare qu'il
faut chérir le plus possible donc oui on
ne sait toujours pas pourquoi est ce
qu'on a construit les menhirs et
peut-être qu'on ne le sera pas mais de
ce que l'on sait et de ce que l'on ne
sait pas on peut apprendre beaucoup de
choses sur nous mêmes je remercie
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]